I have some stunning video for you today.
This is a literal deep platforming. Someone
was pushed off of the platform from which
they were speaking a literal platform, a stage.
I'm talking about a father Marcello Rossi
preaching at a retreat in Sao Paolo, Brazil.
He is an extremely anti gay priest, very,
very homophobic. A couple of examples back
in 1998 he said, quote, a lot of ideas will
change the day. Homosexuality is proven to
be an illness. In 2014 he said, quote, sex
between men causes pain. If something causes
pain, it can't be a good thing. Interesting.
I wonder if he would apply that to aerobic
exercise as well or if maybe there's a different
standard applied there, so in any case, Marcello
Rossi is preaching and the initial, this is
an important thing to mention, the initial
reports about this word that he was preaching
about how fat women don't go to heaven at
the moment that a woman ran on stage and pushed
him off. We've since learned that that appears
not to be the case. I'm going to play the
video here for you. You will see a woman run
onstage and shove him off. This is the mother
of a three year old that was at the retreat
and it appears that this is really a case
of someone suffering from mental health issues.
Let's take a look. Yes as moles,
no mice, because these [inaudible] I says
most PTC [inaudible] peace [inaudible].
So again, the controversy was that it was
initially claimed that the priest was preaching
about how fat women can't go to heaven at
the time that the woman ran on stage and pushed
him off, the implication was it was a direct
response to the viral nature of what he was
saying. Uh, it appears that that was not the
case. He was reportedly preaching about how
his hands belonged to Jesus, which, uh, maybe
just as Kooky in the eyes of nonbelievers
as anything else that he might've been saying,
but it was not fat women can't go to heaven.
A M A and then it seems that this really was
more about, um, um, a mentally ill person
sadly than anything else. Although this guy
is horrifically anti-gay and any opportunity
to point out that there are these uh, sort
of, they are established, they are almost
like codified homophobes.
This is a priest with a following and regularly
speaking to large audiences, uh, about, uh,
how bad also, you know, anything LGBT related
is, uh, it's still an opportunity to mention
that this is going on. Um, I have to be very
clear that I'm against violence like this.
I'm against this priest. I'm against his ideas.
I'm also against homophobia. Uh, but I don't
know that we really achieved much by shoving
the guy off the stage. Or if it was indeed
just a mentally ill person who was acting
in a way that was dissociated from sort of
common sense and rational thinking, then that's
what it was. If it was an act against the
speech of the priest, I don't believe that
this is how those who are in favor of LGBT
rights, those who are defenders of all of
the things that we on the left defend. Uh,
I don't think we achieve our goals with this
type of action. If you disagree though, let
me know. I know there is a sliver of our audience
that has more of a tendency towards using
physical violence to try to achieve political
goals, and I'm open to hearing from everybody.
Make sure you're following me
on Instagram at David Dot pacman. You can
also follow the David Pakman show on Instagram
at David
Package